[Music]
[Applause]
the rocky horror picture show premiered
45 years ago i remember when i first saw
the movie i thought are they really
doing that
can they do that countless screenings
later it's now the longest running movie
in cinema history
it just struck there's like an arrow in
the heart it's all thanks to the
community of die hard fans who celebrate
rocky horror's
warped perspective let me show you a
rhyme
maybe play your simon
you look like you both pretty groovin
the rocky horror picture show first hit
theaters in 1975 a big screen adaptation
of a successful theatrical production in
london
i see you shiver with anticipation
the movie starred susan sarandon barry
bostwick
future rock star meatloaf and tim curry
who originated the role of dr
frankenferder in the stage
how show that despite a meagre reception
at the box office
rocky horror slowly crept its way up to
cultural phenomenon
the general public was not ready for
anything like that
the kids were the flick developed a fan
movement unprecedented
in cinema i mean it happened i suppose
because four or five people
were smashed one day and went dressed as
the characters and
and it just sort of took off from new
york weekly midnight screenings evolved
into an immersive theater experience
and in short time they were popping up
across the country
it went on to be the biggest cult film
in history
people line up to see it a hundred times
they dress like the characters and throw
things at the screen
that's why we're opening tim and me one
stop
rocky horror shop here
all the rocky horror props you need
under one roof while the movie played on
screen
shadow casts dressed as the characters
and reenacted scenes
what all the parents are worried about
is that what's going on in the audience
can't blame us for that the audience got
in on the fun by ceremoniously throwing
items at the screen
and of course dancing the time warp i
don't know i think i mean people are
writing papers on it now
breaking down the barrier between film
and the audience i get sort of very
earnest
students of sociology saying you know
will you read my term paper
for many going to a rocky horror
midnight screening turned into a seminal
coming of age experience
the little kids start talking about have
you seen the rocky horror show and they
aim to be able to go to sea i think it's
become a rights of passage
i see it as sort of a coming of age
experience too
when they reach the age of 12 or 13 they
finally grow up enough
and become an adult and they can go see
the rocky horror picture show on
saturday night
i remember i played the record enough
that i had to buy it
again i wasn't allowed to see it i've
been a fan ever since i used to sneak it
and watch it
all the time until my mom finally walked
in on me one day and i tried to stop it
and it wouldn't stop
rocky horror went from underground hit
to mainstream
good evening my name is jim carrey even
becoming part of jim carrey's early
stand-up comedy
what's in the snap over the years rocky
horror has received
all kinds of pop culture tributes i've
one thing to say
and that's damn it janet i love you
it was a great opportunity to do because
i think we're all show is all about
being an outcast and i think that rocky
horror
is a show for outcasts to go to and in
2016
the musical was reimagined for a
star-studded tv production
quickly feel you tiny fools i think one
of the most special things about rocky
horrors is the theme of it has
remained true if be yourself be true to
yourself and explore
uh who you were meant to be in a
groundbreaking portrayal
laverne cox was cast as dr frankenferter
i'm shawn terry what's really
interesting to me about
this character is that she is she's an
alien and i think one of the most
powerful things about
the rocky horror picture show is that
for over 40 years it has been a symbol
for people who are identified as lgbt or
queer in some way it's appropriate
that our frank and furter is a woman now
and a trans woman
laverne hit upon the biggest part of
rocky horror's legacy
for anyone who's ever felt different or
maybe they'd like to
there's a one-of-a-kind cinema
experience waiting for the next
generation
to step into the roles of janet dr scott
janet rooker i suppose it's about people
that are outside of society and find
their way in
i would like to think it's because it
encourages people to have dreams
not just to dream something but to be it
and that
it's all about whatever you are is all
right
[Music]